okay so over the weekend there was a fox
news channel interview the interviewer
was laura ingraham the interviewee was
the former president donald trump
this is a very relevant interview for
the next two election cycles now that
it's clear they would try the coup again
if they could
now that it's clear donald trump is
planning to be involved in 2022 and
quite plausibly in 2024
now that we know that the coup had a
powerpoint i mean all of the stuff this
must be taken really really seriously so
we're going to go through a number of
different lies told by trump but we're
going to really build to
the commentary about what may be coming
in the future for the united states so
first just to reintroduce us to the
uncontrollable lying donald trump again
makes very deceptive and untrue claims
about gas prices now
why the gas price issue is even an issue
remember there's a lot of people who
play the political football of blaming
or praising presidents for high or low
gas prices depending on what is
convenient based on your partisan
affiliation i don't play that game
presidents have almost nothing to do
with gas prices but trump plays the game
he says when he left office gas was at
1.87 and now it's at 777 in california
if those numbers sound weird they should
and uh let's look at the clip first you
look at gas prices uh gasoline was at
1.87 cents a gallon and now in
california it's over
7.77 to be exact
and it's going to be catching up with a
lot of other parts of the country so
okay
so it's all either a lie or deceptive
when trump left office
gas was a dollar eighty seven he says
that's not true
when trump left office gas was 242. so
is it higher today yes but was it a
dollar 87 no when trump left office it
was 30 higher at 242.
trump says gas is now 777 in california
and what's dishonest about that well
even if it were true that gas prices are
777 in california comparing california
to the national number doesn't make
sense the official national gas price is
now 349. so you don't compare 187 or the
real number 242 a year ago or when you
left office to a specific gas station in
california that doesn't make sense you
compare it to the official number in the
us and that is now 349. it's 349 instead
of 242. is gas more now than when trump
left yes
it is dramatically uh uh it's a
dramatically smaller gap than what trump
claimed and remember presidents don't
control gas prices now lastly
even the california number is a lie
california gas right now
uh the national the official the
official state number is 460.
not 777.
is there some gas station in california
where super premium
maybe was 777 maybe i don't know but
that's not how you look at numbers so
it's all lies and he keeps telling them
trump then says and this is totally
unintelligible he he's like his brain is
glitching it's like mayonnaise
um or veganism trump claims democrats
are going to try to use the debt ceiling
for the supreme court and other stuff i
don't even know what he's saying take a
listen to absolutely kill that now
they're going to use it for the supreme
court and even worse than that they're
going to use it for the so-called voting
rights which is a disaster for our
country and certainly it's a disaster
for the republican party
yeah i don't think that's going to pass
but um arizona just off the wall
off the wall no idea what mechanisms
he is even referring to trump was then
asked about invoking or attempting to
invoke executive privilege even though
he's no longer president over documents
related to the january 6th trump riots
and he again says
there was no insurrection on january 6th
the insurrection was election day
november of 2020. this is his new
talking point and i'll explain it in a
moment head here about the executive
privilege and biden's decision to
release those documents your reaction
tonight
well we're gonna have to see what
happens uh if you look at the
protest it was a protest the
insurrection took place on november
third which was election day this was a
protest that a lot of innocent people
are being hurt a lot of innocent people
are being injured
i would say the panel of judges that
we're talking about didn't exactly like
trump
and if you look at the appointments you
can figure that one out for yourself but
this was a absolute protest and people
are being treated very very unfairly
their rights are being taken away from
them and the other side is not you take
a look at what's going on with blm and
antifa what they did in portland and
minneapolis and seattle and nothing
happens but what happened by the way
people were killed nobody was killed
here other than ashley babbitt who was
shot violently by a man that should not
have ever been allowed to pull that
trigger
okay so so the
the talk the story is trump says
that what happened on january 6th was
not a coup it was not an insurrection
and my supporters weren't violent
the it was blm and antifa if anyone was
violent but otherwise it was a peaceful
protest
the real insurrection was when they
stole it from me him
in november of 2020 and he also
continues to insist that all of these
hundreds of defendants the rioters
were um actually
innocent and now are being treated
poorly it's wild i mean these and now is
where it starts to get dangerous because
people believe this stuff
and they're going to try it again in
2024 with trump or with someone else
trump then attacks attacks the makeup of
the january 6th committee and says they
aren't real republicans it's only
kinzinger and cheney but why is that
well let's look at the clip and then
i'll explain
we have
liz cheney and kinzinger
two people that should not be on the
committee we don't have republicans on
the uh i call it the unselect committee
of democrat partisans it's ridiculous
what's going on with it and he has done
a terrible job you have the i call it
the infrastructure bill because it's not
infrastructure so trump says they don't
have real republicans they only have
people like adam kinzinger and liz
cheney well that's because other
republicans abandoned the initial plan
for the committee and said we're not
going to participate which made nancy
pelosi have to go out and find
republicans willing to be on it does it
mean we wouldn't prefer a different make
up of the commitment no of course not
but
come on it's another deceptive claim
so here's what's very clearly going on
trump is dramatically accelerating the
pace of his media interviews over the
last two weeks why
the 2022 midterms are about to start
he's ramping up for 2022 he wants to be
the king maker he wants people donating
to him so that through his pack he can
support candidates he is definitely
going to be involved in campaigns in
2022 and then
this is all part of the build-up
to try again with any means necessary
any means they can get away with
in 2024 there is no doubt now whether
the candidate will be trump
that's a different question we don't
know the answer to that yet over the
last 10 days more and more people saying
it's gonna be trump
uh i think his health may be the biggest
limiting factor we just don't know yet
but this is building he's doing
interviews more and more frequently to
sell the book sure but also because we
are about to get very much in
with uh what might be some of the most
anticipated i mean it sounds cliche but
in a way what is going to happen will
democrats uh lose everything
other than the white house in november
of 22 or not and uh trump wants to be
very much involved
one of our sponsors is kamikoto making
elegant high-end beautiful japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan i've been a
big fan of japanese kitchen knives for a
long time they have some great
advantages when you look closely at a
kamikoto knife you see the quality of
the iron work they only use japanese
steel every knife comes in a perfect
heavy duty ash wood box makes storage
really easy it looks great in your
kitchen or drawer the balance of the
knives is just amazing i've been using
them for everything every knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee on their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at michelin star restaurants who
use kamikoto and through this
partnership they're doing with us
kamikoto is giving you 50 off on top of
their other special offers just go to
camikoto.com
pacman and use the code pacman for 50
off the link is down below